[Music]
my name is lily colson
and i'm 18 years old these are my three
best friends
m bex and sarah
and this is the 100 true story of how my
town
salem lost its [ __ ] mind
but let's start at the beginning
actually not here because what i did
that afternoon was really gross
whoa the principal [ __ ] got hacked
dude's [ __ ] butt i don't have like
any sympathy
for people that get their [ __ ] hacked
for real there's two types of people in
this world
people that have come to terms with
privacy is just dead
then there's the old people that are
still trying to fight it what do you
have to hide anyway though
a million nudes super gross porn history
like life-altering [ __ ] talk about
everyone in this school
i think it was some like socially
conscious vigilante hacker guy
probably jack's off to fight club in his
mom's basement like every night
looks like half a salem just got hacked
i hate the [ __ ] internet when
seventeen thousand
people's texts and emails get leaked
[ __ ] gets really [ __ ] weird
we got some salem [ __ ] on the ride
slaying my
[Music]
who sees a naked photo of a girl and
their first thought is
yo i gotta kill this [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
you think you're going barry
way more people than you'd think
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] you this is your world
you built this don't take your hate out
on me i just got here
you may kill me but she can't kill us
all
you sure you even know how to hold that
thing little girl
[Music]
you